[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the political
editors of the daily mirror and the sun
pipakura and harry cole they'll be with
us right until just before midnight so
let's see then what's on those front
pages starting with the guardian a
report being published overnight will
say the government's early handling of
the coronavirus pandemic represented one
of the worst public health failures in
uk history
on that same story the metro has the
headline shamed over covert chaos
quoting the report the daily mail says
the elderly were treated as an
afterthought during the pandemic
the dilemma calls the belated
implementation of the first lockdown the
deadliest of delays
meanwhile the telegraph hears the
influential right-wing think tank the
institute for fiscal studies believes
that further tax rises will be necessary
to pay for health and social care
the times says the prime minister has
backed a multi-million pound bailout for
industries feeling the impact of higher
gas prices
the delhi express leads with retailers
pulling out all the stops to meet
christmas demand
while the daily star laments the
possible loss of plastic ketchup bottles
in favor of environmentally friendly
glass ones
it's going backwards to go forwards
isn't it anyway we will uh we'll park
that one for the moment uh pippa and
harry cole are here and many of the
newspapers pippa including your own the
daily mirror are uh reflecting on this
parliamentary report which is out
overnight tonight about the initial
stages and the government response to
the pandemic uh your paper uh part of
the it has to be said excoriating
coverage tonight calling it the
deadliest of delays tell us more
well we've gone in on the line in the
report that um the mps criticized the
government for the delay in bringing in
the first lockdown saying it led to tens
of thousands of unnecessary deaths but
there are lots of other lines in this
report which is 150 pages long
and when i read it later
when i read it earlier um going through
some of the criticisms over the handling
of the social care
sector over um the restrictions which
were brought in
the preparedness health inequalities and
the list goes on and much of it
are issues that we've discussed um and
thought about a lot over the last 18
months of the pandemic not least because
many of the evidence sessions were in
public there was obviously written
submissions as well and you'll remember
the explosive testimony from the likes
of dominic cummings
we had matt hancocks and simon stevens
the head of the nhs and as well as the
the government's medical and scientific
advisors so much of the arguments that
uh the criticisms which are being uh
published in the report were rehearsed
at those so there's not very many
surprises but what really is striking is
that this is the first time the overview
has been brought together in this way
and as we all know boris johnson has
been under huge pressure to bring
forward the um the independent public
inquiry which he said he wants to hold
uh not before next spring and so this is
almost being a sort of an alternative
public inquiry if you like into those
failings coming much sooner as it has
and it really i think just
makes you sort of take stock and step
back a bit and think as we're emerging
from the pandemic and obviously the
vaccines the report also praises the
vaccines we're alive
um really what a terrible terrible 18
months it's been
well emerging from the pandemic with a
massive caseload every day it has to be
pointed out but you look at the coverage
overnight of the newspapers the metro 2
shamed over covered chaos and you think
doesn't matter how much you sing about
the vaccine rollout what were they doing
in those early months harry
yeah i think i think they've been spot
on there is a huge amount of surprises
we've slightly gone round the houses a
little bit on this and we're going to be
going around the houses on this for for
years and years to come and and and so
be it if that means that next time
um we are in a better position and
better prepared i think um
it's a weird feeling of back in back in
march 2020 when
um you know february the sort of you
know the the stories were growing the
numbers were you know cases were lapping
uh at british shores and you looked
across the pond to uh to places like
italy
and you just sort of thought behind the
scenes
surely
there is someone dusting down a document
that says right what do we do in this
scenario what is the plan and i think
one of the most startling um parts of
this of this inquiry and past this uh
report is just how bad the planning had
been for any of this and it makes you
really wonder you know what other
contingency plans have we got for all
sorts of horrific awful things that
could happen to this country and god
forbid they would and are we in any fit
shape or prepare for them if a pandemic
which was quite high on the list of
possibilities of things that could
happen
um
was was so poorly prepared for and
that's what really chilled me about it
um you know we can we can go through the
greatest hits of dominic cummings
they're all in there you know it's laid
fairly bad how
how quite how much money was wasted
on test and trace in those early days
you know what is the point of having
this massive testing capacity if there's
no if there's no you know if there's no
tracing element that can actually use it
to to shut down so that's that's all
there and as pippa said there is you
know you know the second half of the of
the report makes a much better reading
about quite how
um once the government has you know been
battered and bruised and beaten around
the head and it did become quite nimble
uh and didn't rip up the rules and did
break all the procurement you know sort
of notions of traditional procurement to
get that vaccine going um so i think you
know it's the first crack at history
it's the first draft obviously you know
dare i say jeremy hunt might not be the
biggest most imp impartial observer on
this one given he was the health
secretary for 10 years well nearly 10
years in the run-up to the pandemic but
um it needed to be done we'll be hearing
lots more reports like this they'll go
into much more granular detail but um
yeah as the papers say tonight the first
draft of history is pretty damning yeah
to be to be fair i mean both of these
committees the health and social care
committee and the science and technology
committee who came together to do this
they're both led by tories though aren't
they so it's
not exactly the opposition like this go
on sorry
no i'm just saying they haven't held
their punches and rightly so however i
suspect the you know i i you know i
suspect the independent inquiry will go
into far more detail it did feel like a
little bit like
actually you know i wouldn't say rush
but you know
it is it does rattle through things
quite quickly without it's very much he
said she said he said she said and this
is what we think whereas actually this
is how a public inquiry work would have
access to all the documents to
everything uh will be will be a much
more granular process and probably given
public inquiries of the past take years
well the uh the guardian also critical
uk's covert failings amongst the worst
in history are saying that ministers and
scientists in fact took a fatalistic
approach that exacerbated the death toll
and i remember when our uh correspondent
stuart ramsey was in the hospitals of
bergamo the first time we'd seen
property inside a hospital and the local
mayor was begging the uk to listen and
take notice and at the time what were
the government doing where was boris
johnson you know he was accused of being
away for various weekends with his uh
his then fiance and he's away now
obviously as we go into the sort of
supply and energy crisis you know where
does the blame start and finish pippa
well ultimately and it's you know it
starts and finishes at the top doesn't
it but so one of the i thought one of
the major missions of this particular
inquiry which i think the public inquiry
will attempt to rectify is that
the families of the bereaved
or the bereaved families um victims um
and those and survivors themselves
weren't actually spoken to and there's
one particular campaign group which i
know conversations with jeremy hunt and
and felt that it had been assured that
they would be heard at the inquiry the
obviously very particular questions that
they wanted answered and um they're you
know feeling angry um tonight that they
weren't included and their voice wasn't
heard i mean around about 150 000 people
have died during this pandemic as a
result of covid i mean that's a massive
number and it's impacted millions of
people's lives very directly because of
that and so it does seem to me like
quite a big omission that that um you
know they they haven't been they haven't
been spoken to and they certainly want
felt that in terms of accountability
coming back to your question i know in
terms of accountability it had to stop
at
the door of the prime minister and they
were trying very hard to get a meeting
with prime minister which finally
happened a couple of weeks ago
um which is you know kind of a first
step i guess um but uh you know it's not
just about the the sort of you know
who's
this committee made clear that um
destroying committee that they didn't
want to point fingers necessarily but
ultimately i think not just the bereaved
but many people across britain will
expect somebody to be held accountable
yes and i know we'll talk about this uh
you know again and as you say over the
weeks and you know when when the public
inquiry comes to just wanted to show
over on the daily mail as well the
elderly were just an afterthought
thousands died in care homes because of
that clearly there was a desperate need
to get people who could leave out of
hospitals uh to make them safer but
possibly not done the right way not done
with the appropriate testing and not
with the ppe that was necessary just
hurry very quickly on that then
yeah that was one of the crucial bits of
actually of the of these sort of
parliamentary sort of fireworks that we
had uh and as this report was given was
taking evidence dom coming saying you
know
matt hancock was dick hunting you know
people into hair care was about
protesting and misled the prime minister
about it hancock coming out swinging
very firmly denying that note that
cummings promised to present evidence
that he had written evidence for that
that failed notably to present to the
committee so
lots of loose ends still to tie up but
um yeah as i as as i said you know it's
a it's a it's a quick first draft of
history and i think there's a few more
issues to be chewed over um again
properly in proper data yeah we're
certainly dominating uh tomorrow's
newspapers is it not harry potter stay
there lots more still to come including
has the government misjudged the public
mood over gas prices talk more about
that after this break
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now peppa carrera
and harry cole welcome back to both of
you um harry let's go straight to your
paper you're exclusive it seems as well
she says chicken that chicken the name
yes it is
and uh this is about uh extra money on
top of the already increasing energy
bills so take it away for us if you can
yeah so as gas bills are soaring already
um boris johnson with the run up to cop
in just two or three weeks time the
climate change summit he's under
pressure and has to his promise to
publish his big net zero green strategy
now unfortunately for the government um
it doesn't rain it pause within that
there's a plan to make electricity over
the next 15 years a lot cheaper and gas
a lot more expensive so
exactly the same time we're having a big
old round about gas prices up up's going
to pop the prime minister and alex
sharma and quasi quatering next week and
try and remain part of the reality-based
community while also suggesting that um
a gas bill should go up by 159 pounds
that's the current subsidy there sorry
it's current green levees that are on
electricity and they want to switch
those over um so there's lots of things
in there in this in this strategy all of
them are going to be quite controversial
i suspect to tory mps who don't want to
rip out their gas boilers in the next 10
years and it's not just consumers is it
if we take a look at the times it's also
those businesses many of them that are
high energy and are thinking about
scaling back production because of the
increasing gas prices uh what's the
suggestion here that they do need state
loans pepper
yeah the discussions going on now
between the department for business and
the treasury are about temporarily
lending them long term though um loans
in order to cover the cost of rising gas
prices this is for energy intensive
industries things like steel and
ceramics and chemicals and so on um that
need a lot of gas and many of the firms
and the sectors have warned in recent
days that they're potentially on the
brink of shutting down some of them
permanently which would be pretty
devastating and potentially lead to
thousands of job losses the suggestion
is the prime minister doesn't want to
oversee that so that he is prepared to
back quasi-quarting over his chancellor
rishi sinak who's more resistant about
about continuing the state splurge in
supporting particular sectors
and we should see more details of those
loans in coming days does it does it
make it even more extraordinary that the
prime minister was so dismissive
of these uh latest difficulties in his
address to the party conference last
week do you think um harry especially as
he's gone gone on holiday the mac
cartoon is uh one of those pointing that
out
yeah a little bit while there's a little
bit feels like when the cat's away
they're sort of mice are playing and as
max tomorrow's got dylan the dog in
charge while whitehall big beast
strips off each other i mean there's an
element of when could the prime minister
ever take a holiday and it's the
parliamentary recess of this week
probably better than taking it in the
middle of the g20 or in copper and run
up to christmas so there's never a good
time for these things but um i would say
that even the even his most vicious
critics aren't being too pro-faced about
the whole thing uh right now but as ever
you know there's always going to be big
beasts the numbers the numbers are so
large now post covered with the terms of
money flying around that actually you
know the tempers are fraying because the
matters are so serious and you know you
have to slightly feel for rishi sunak
who you know has just spent 407 billion
pounds on kobe recovery and is now you
know the wolf is at the door again
rattling that tin asking for more money
i would hate him to add though for prime
minister a lot of these energy intensive
uh
industries are in red wool seats
ceramics glass and stoke on trent